ces déchets là c'est une valeur ajoutée
on peut créer beaucoup d'emplois au lieu
d'apporter ses déchaîna des autres pays
elle de perdre des devises on peut les
utiliser en tunisie
[Musique]
l'état est en train de pays
à peu près entre 150 et 200 dinars par
tonne des prêts pour faire
l'enfouissement de déchets transport des
prix de ces et en europe et d autres
pays ils voient que ces déchets là dans
une richesse beaucoup dizaine
d'instructeurs en europe ils ont investi
dans le décès est pour gagner de
l'argent
[Musique]
si le l'habitant ne paye pas pour
assurer à chaque fois le coût de
traitement on aura jamais de projets et
là c'est le blocage le blocage qu'on a
accueilli
[Musique]